is October twice is nice well it's back
to Strasburg for the second time this
month as migration at the sakharov prize
and GMOs a future big at the plenary
welcome to the agenda extraordinary
meeting of EU leaders on the migrant
crisis continue another is plant a
Sunday to try to help Western Balkan
countries cope for the influx of
migrants the migratory route for
Refugees bound for Germany is through
these countries but they're bulking
under the pressure hungary has closed
its borders and Slovenia has just passed
legislation to get the army to police
its borders leaving many migrants
trapped with winter fast approaching the
EU needs to get its act together and
tuesday there'll be a debate with the EU
council president donald tusk and
Commission President jean-claude Juncker
on decisions taken by EU leaders were
the weather like today an exotic holiday
wouldn't go miss it said that consumers
lose over billion euros every year due
to a lack of sufficient cover while
traveling abroad rules are being updated
to provide greater protection on package
deals the scope is being widened beyond
the traditional deal on flights and
accommodation taking into account the
way in which people shop around for the
best deals MEP is vote on Tuesday in
Strasburg but at committee level any
piece of a special tax committee will
put a report to a vote that looks to
ensure better tax practices across the
continent the vote on Monday comes as
both starbucks and Fiat have been
ordered to pay back at the 30 million
euros in taxes for being given unfair
advantage in Holland and Luxembourg
respectively the report goes before the
full house in November new legislation
that we give member states the right to
restrict all ban at gmos could actually
be voted down in Strasbourg the
Environment Committee and many political
families want the house to eject the
legislative proposal they say it's not
feasible and could lead to border
control tensions between proponents and
opponents of GMOs find out what happens
at the vote on Wednesday
championing a cause that delights MEP
will put to a vote legislation our aims
to end roaming charges the legislation
would end roaming charges by 2017 but if
that's too far to wait don't forget that
by the end of April next year a voice
calls will only cost you five cents a
minute text messages two cents and data
five cents per megabyte let me underline
this the 2015 work program came with a
tagline and you start over to Commission
first vice president France timmermans
who will unveil the exact his priorities
for the year ahead and don't forget the
recipient for the Sakharov Prize 2015
will also be unveiled in Strasbourg will
it be right for Dowie the Venezuelan
opposition or Boris Nemtsov and that's
all we have for this agenda take care
and enjoy the week